beautiful shot beautiful shot of the
intrepid here in new york city president
trump says he aced his cognitive test
and is demanding that joe biden take one
too but it doesn't look like the former
bp is going to do that anytime soon
biden scolding a reporter in a very
weird way
for daring to ask him about it and also
mocking president trump
watch no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you a joke well if he can't figure
out the difference between an elephant
and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
now that is a word salad uh lawrence
i'll go to you first
does he not recognize that there is a
question about his cognitive debility
and taking it on
might be in his interest well i don't
know if he's unaware
or it could be denial but i i mean
i'm not going to speak on his mental
health but what i will say because i'm
not a doctor but i will say this
is as a guy that was elected to office
for 47 years
i think is intellectually dishonest to
say that this is a different joe biden
right he was once known as the greatest
retail
politician the campaigns would want him
out talking with people
his press aides loved him talking to the
press even though sometimes he would
turn some heads he had a strategic way
of connecting with people
that has since changed they do not want
him talking with the person when he
talks with the press
they are layups that they set up for him
they do not want him out talking with
people because of
the scene or the potential of them
asking questions and so
there is a different joe biden i think
they have to be honest about that
and plan a strategy to uh to combat that
i now to the people that would say well
donald trump as well
now if you dislike what donald trump
says or like what he says
i think it's one thing that to say that
he's been consistent
all these years he's been the same
donald trump now if you say that you
dislike what he says
that's one argument but i don't think
there's a question of mental stability
that people are saying they just don't
like what he has to say which is fair
too
juan if that's a layup he missed it now
i'm going to play a flashback
of what former vice president biden said
about cognitive tests
earlier listen i've been tested and i'm
constantly testing look
all you all i got to do is watch me and
i can hardly
wait to compare my cognitive capability
to the cognitive capability of the man
i'm running against
so juan d does he believe that almost
the same question do you believe that
why would he say he took the test
and then say no i don't need to take the
test and then bizarrely berate a
reporter
and ask him if he's a junkie is that
something you want from your candidate
pete i think he was so right and smart
to fire back
aggressively at that question because i
was just listening to you and lawrence
and it's clear
that there's some people who want to
portray joe biden as a doddering old
fool who would be best put away by his
family
and he's just not that uh you know dana
perrino
asked jill biden about this yesterday
and she was very clear
this guy has all his faculties in fact
what else would a spouse say hang on let
me finish
well no you could say that but she was
honest and so here's the thing
when president trump took a cognitive
test
he thought somehow he he said he was
bragging about it like it was an iq test
this is a test given to people who may
have alzheimer's dementia have had a
stroke
and he's talking about it bragging about
it to people it's just
it was not rational but nobody's you
know i think it's a little bit i
admire lawrence for saying he's not a
doctor we're not doctors
but i think this is a political slander
job aimed
at there's no difference but he's right
to firebase
there's no difference in joe biden no
difference let me just say i ran into
joe biden
earlier this year and joe biden as in
joe biden's style
was talking my air off and still
lawrence a
great not average great retail
politician
so so dana we may not be able to play
the doctor game here but we can play the
dc
game let's put it in reverse if
president trump was showing the same
signs
unwilling to go out on the campaign
trail would the media be treating him
the same way they're treating
joe biden with kid gloves well i think
we know that
conservatives definitely get a tougher
time from the media
in every case this president gets a lot
of it
um so yeah of course i i think that the
debates are the best place for
the question of cognitive abilities to
be solved by the american people who are
going to make a decision
i i don't think that this is a good use
of time
for uh the trump campaign and i think
you see that because they started
shifting their
uh focus to be what you were talking
about in the a block
p which is about the policies and the
consequences
of the policies and so they had done
their research they knew that it wasn't
working as well but they still stick on
it
i also feel like there should be a
reverse in the media strategy
like i think president trump is
everywhere
all day long and i know that that his
base loves to see him but if they were
to take a step back
and then have the media focus on the
fact that joe biden is not out there
and the only thing that they could use
to talk about the 2020 race was his
interview this morning
that would put a lot more focus on joe
biden
than basically stepping on that message
all day long well the president will be
on shortly here in about 10 minutes if
he's on schedule
to your point dana but but emily do you
think we did hear it's true
earlier the whole sleepy joe mantra
playing on the cognitive ability it
seems the trump campaign has shifted
more to
here's what he would unleash on the
country is it good
is it useful politically in your mind to
be talking about this
because it is a real issue if you're
going to be the leader of the free world
i think it's useful and apt that they
started
discussing or attacking his policies
because remember he hadn't unveiled them
before
so prior to that prior to him revealing
that essentially he's
putting forth bernie and aoc's policies
it was just about him being sleepy joe
what i took away from that interview
because i'm not a doctor is his
inability to handle any type of
prompting
question i took away his demeanor with
an immediate raised hackles
and an attack and to me that's what
we're going to see more of in whenever
he is allowed to be
to debate the president right now and
that would have been an opportunity to
him to say
firmly and like a leader does i'm quite
confident in my
cognitive ability and here's why and let
me tell you a little bit more about how
that's going to further my problem i
mean you know it's it's not
rocket science for him to have responded
in a way that reassured us
without playing into that game and final
point democrats best strategy was to let
the media
attack the president while joe biden
sort of hung out and reveled in the
memory that americans have of him being
attached to joe
to uh president obama but because he's
now out
what we're seeing is obviously going to
be imprinted on americans mind so
president trump would be smart to let
his team
amplify this among the electorate and
take a step back from engaging in it
himself
juan i'm going to double down briefly on
what lawrence said to you do you really
feel
confident that joe biden on the stage
whether the dates are moved or not
can go toe-to-toe with president trump
where he is right now he hasn't had
the warm-up the way candidates normally
would on the trail he's been in his
basement
would he do are you truly confident that
he's capable of that
yeah i mean i i'm i'm i'm listening to
you and and trying to respect this
concept because we just saw him in an
interview that you guys played and said
you didn't like the response
i think he should fire back aggressively
and say this is nonsense
but you know what i mean as dana said
we'll see we'll have the debates the
american people can be the judge
but if you saw the axios interview of
the chris wallace interview
you'd have to say the one that seems to
be not in touch with the facts
i think he's in the white house well
there there has been no
interviews yeah there has been no chris
wallace interview for joe biden to
lawrence's point
uh all right